I've been doing this for a long time and
you think you've seen everything and I
say that probably every year a couple of
times a year yep
I've seen that and I always say that
there's always something new this is my
Hollywood love sports because they give
you an ending where you go you can't
script them and I was watching the
highlights on Sunday morning I saw the
headline and it talked about Newtown I
ended up winning the state championship
on the final play so I go into the story
and I want to see how they wanted and
they wanted in dramatic fashion now let
me give you the whole scene here seven
years to the day after the Sandy Hook
shooting that killed 26 elementary
school children and staff Newtown faced
darian High School for the championship
you have under four seconds to go the
game is time and you got terrible
weather there but you're armed with Jack
street who's your quarterback
by the way a great name Jack Street and
that Hollywood will be ready for Jack
Street I think Riley Ward is the wide
receiver and you see this play and I
can't see the ball and then I see the
end result where they score the
touchdown and then it just it was this
moment of I don't even know how to
describe that but coaches in here Jack
Street and also Bobby Patterson is the
head coach the coach your reaction once
you saw that ball in the air like you
said I really couldn't see it myself one
of my assistants was I was on the
headphones with he says he's open he's
open he's open and then the place was
absolute mayhem I couldn't hear anything
everybody started running onto the field
and I was running running around looking
for somebody to hug well they don't have
a like a guide book that says this is
what you do after a dramatic
championship game yeah no not at all
Riley Ward who caught the pass he ran to
the corner everybody followed and and
and and just absolutely speechless
speechless and then just full of emotion
you just it just hit you in as we just
won this to class double all state
championship on the last play like a
walk-off Jack take me into the huddle
what's the play we we call it we changed
the play in the timeout we called it was
originally corner post and we changed
the post corners and the sideline
and threw the ball to a spot wait I'm
gonna hear that huh I'm in the huddle
with you right now give me the gun
we we had a we had to call a play called
called it was corner post and we saw
something at the we said we're gonna
change it to post corner and everyone
was on board
wait are you fired up like you go kid
guys this is I mean really the champion
we had no idea we had no idea that it
was it was gonna work out that way it
was unbelievable but did you know that
where you were you were going to Riley
for yes like that was the planet oh we
move Riley from the left to the right
Riley is an outstanding wide receiver
but he's great at double moves and we
saw a single high safety so I called a
timeout right there before and I said I
would move on when we changed it double
move to the corner look at you holla
check the kids the kids made me look
good that's that's what it boils down to
and then our outside receiver ran a
speed out and we're trying to put the
corner in a bind he he bit on the out
and created some space for for the for
the double move and Jack delivered Jack
what did you see I saw the corner take
the five out like he said and Riley beat
the safety and right when the safety
turned his hips I threw it to his spun
they ran under it made a play but did
you see him catch it yeah pretty much I
was trying to look around my linemen I
was just in shock I was like I don't
know what just happened but what
happened next I sprinted down the field
I saw Riley throw his helmet I did the
same thing I tossed in the air and it
was a celebration all over the field
what did you think coach behind again I
think a lot of people there's three
seconds left we are too far for a field
goal
we called the play and we you know we're
taking a shot and the kids executed but
a lot of everybody was saying like well
how's it working how does work in
overtime so everybody in their head
starts thinking well this game looks
like it's going overtime what exactly
are the rules and overtime again that
yeah that's what the assistant coaches
are talking about in the head SATs a
little bit and and but we didn't even
need to get there because or we need to
go there because
wanted on the last play what did I miss
after the celebration we only saw the
clip I could hear the you know everybody
excited and you guys throw in your
helmets yeah we ate we had our entire
town in the stands and I think everyone
was on the field from the stands they
just came on the field and celebrated
with us it's the kind of situation where
and you don't know this now because
you're just a junior but you're this
will be with you for the rest of your
life that moment will be with you the
rest of your life and you don't want it
to end like you don't I'm gonna guess
you didn't want to leave the field now
it was it was the best feeling my life
and I can't even explain it is the
importance of this team to this
community like can you can you let the
audience in on how important this is
with everything you've been there as a
coach you've been there as a player yeah
it's a it's an emotional time to win a
state championship is extremely
difficult so I'm proud so proud of these
young men for doing that but again
falling on the date that we played the
game it's the community kind of rallied
behind us and and everybody was there
and and everybody understood what the
day we're playing a football game on a
very emotional day for a lot of people
and to win it in the win it in the
fashion that we did is tremendous I've
had numerous people reach out to me at
outpouring of support and and so many
people are happy and I've said this
before sports are so powerful that they
can bring people together and in moments
like this you said it before Hollywood
you can't script a better ending you
know I kind of think back like like this
everybody knows the day but I think back
I was in high school you know home was
20 or little less than 20 years ago and
I remember George Bush throwing out the
first pitch and the World Series out of
that after 9/11 and it's like you know
you remember those things they're
powerful foe so for our community this
was this was big for many of many of the
people involved and they're gonna
remember this or express their life I
hope there's a celebration you know
because I don't know if there's a parade
planned but just to see joy out of that
community that's what hit me when I saw
that video I didn't want it to end
because I I just thought and this is a
nation that really looked at this story
and embraced this this wasn't just a
little small hey you won the state
championship
like do you guys see this because this
is what I do for a living I see it
nationally
you guys probably see it locally the
nation embraced this ya know they they
definitely day to have where we've been
a lot of people have been reaching out
to us I don't know if they're gonna be
doing a parade or anything like that but
I I don't know I mean that's that's not
my decision to make but let's go we'll
get a parade guy on Paulie get afraid
we're on it we want a parade for these
guys here no class today Jack I'm here
also when they say I need a note from
your doctor do I have to sign a note
that allows you to miss school today I
guess I guess that's my excuse of the
day what is school gonna be like when
you go back it's me great it's gonna be
so fun seeing everyone that was at the
game everyone that was ruined for us and
I saw them all on the field after the
game so where's the football I got it in
the office it's in the office right now
so and then this week I'm gonna have all
the seniors sign it and we'll end up in
a trophy case and we'll put the score
air date on everything so it'll be yeah
be good for us to have that ball
Jack you don't get to sign it does the
school have any other championships of
this magnitude we won state
championships in other sports okay I'm
just you know but but this is the most
obviously the most recent one and I'm
sure there'll be more our sports program
at Newtown is just tremendous a lot of
good good sports teams you've had the
Today Show talk about this football
night in America talk about this today
you're with us what's the outpouring
been like we were we were on football
night in America of last night and they
were great and I think think everybody
is it's been tremendously positive it
really has and a lot of people look at
it as as this is something that is good
it's a it's a very positive story that's
coming out of this and and again these
kids are great kids and they worked
tremendously hard throughout the year we
set goals in the beginning and winning a
state championship and to work as hard
as they did over the course of the year
and to reach those goals and then to
reach him in the
and win on the last play just
unbelievable you're gonna be big man on
campus now Jack right our whole team but
you know what I and I will applaud the
you know people behind the scenes that
Newtown who understood the sensitivity
of this and reached out to say please
handle this with care like they wanted
to make sure that we celebrated a
football team in a football environment
that you did something on a day of an
anniversary of one of the worst
tragedies we've ever had in in our
country and I hope that we didn't lose
sight of that with this I because you
guys live this it's every single day
you're reminded constantly you see
parents Jack you have a teammate who I
believe lost you know a sibling in this
I mean that the sensitivity I hope has
been there and I hope you guys continue
to receive that but I hope it allows
people to just smile or forget for a
moment there if that's possible and if
you did that then you did a wonderful
thing so I hope you take that away coach
yeah
well thank you thank you Jack Congrats
it's a big big moment if there's
something you want to say before you
know we go to commercial break that's
really mom and dad always thanked mom
and dad and now you got to come up with
an encore cuz now we need back-to-back
titles okay during the commercial break
we have a football field out there so we
figured we could recreate this play is
that all right yeah don't worry yeah you
can throw do some old guys yeah don't
don't throw to me don't throw to me I'll
let you coach coach Bobby Patterson Jack
Street Newtown High School head coach
and star quarterback won the state
championship they want to hold up more
than just that for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR Live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]